wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
es war der beste abend seit langer zeit
das finde ich auch erinnerst du dich
noch an die tollen partys damals war ja
unsere nachbarn haben einiges mitgemacht
zum glück haben sie sich selten über die
laute musik aufgeregt die party zum
pudel club dass man die tollsten wir
sind nie vor sonnenaufgang nach hause
gegangen und man ist nach einer guten
fee auch nie alleine nach hause gegangen
du vielleicht nicht ich weiß ich
vermisse die alten zeiten ja manches
davon vermisse ich und manches auch
nicht was meinst du
naja ich bin noch glücklich wieso sollte
ich also irgendetwas anderes vermissen
du kannst nur glücklich sein wenn du
etwas vermissen kannst ja du weißt schon
immer die klügere von uns beiden
[Musik]
ich mag dein laden
ich mach's gut
[Musik]